diese bilder berühren zutiefst in minsk
spitzt sich die lage wieder zu heute
wurden hunderte demonstrierende frauen
verhaftet unter ihnen nina bei ginski
die 73 jährige wurde zu einer ikone des
widerstands in weißrussland hier sehen
wir sie wie sie sich nach lukaschenko
eliteeinheit mutig widersetzte jetzt hat
der präsident mit aller härte
durchgegriffen hat sie und weitere
frauen die friedlich demonstrieren
verhaftet in belarus gehen seit wochen
vor allem frauen auf die straße um gegen
die diktatur von lukaschenko zu
demonstrieren mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren